[Music]
[Applause]
does he know the TV's the other way
surveys some commercials Chips Ahoy
there's new sprinkle Chips Ahoy yep it's
that time again to tore down the often
forgotten but fondly remembered avenue
of nostalgic commercials why do so many
of them stay with us what is it about
the world of pandering and advertising
that makes us so fond of Valerie
whatever it is we're gonna review them
and partake in their corniness once more
so see how the first one I called will
be right back and the second one after
these messages and the third one
explanation point this one I'm gonna
call good old Chef Boyardee causing
children around the world to grow up and
shout I can't believe I used to put this
in my body dinosaurs from Chef Boyardee
tastes wholesome pasta that's a dinosaur
hunt tasty wholesome pasta I can think
of three things wrong with that sentence
thank goodness for you pac-man pasta
from Chef Boyardee smell of course
making famous characters into edible
shapes is nothing new there was pac-man
Smurfs help even take TechEd Oh got a
pasta some people forget is that for the
longest time they tried to make a game
out of eating their products yeah listen
and when you get three etches or rows of
your spoon you win because first one to
capture all three dinosaur shapes wins
why must you turn dinnertime into a
competitive sport one the more
appropriate rules be hey kids if you can
eat the elbow macaroni in ketchup we're
calling pasta without vomiting it up
through your ears nose or mouth you win
look at this crazy kid he's jacked up on
the stuff just look at face it's like he
saw Jesus and at the same time decided
he wanted to eat him well even if you
don't like the food Chef Boyardee always
knew how to give us that tasty amount of
goofiness tikka tikka tikka tacos
with and without meatballs Oh Oh God you
can't help but feel that warm fuzzy
feeling whenever you watch this classic
[Music]
really it's a McDonald's commercial
about a little girl thinking about
running away and for some reason never
questions the creepy clown that's on our
neighbors lawn McDonald and that's where
I'm from I hear it's a dictatorship
where people disappear well Lindsay
maybe there's some undesirables they are
holding back genetic progress
I hear where you're from is really nice
- it's so calm because you've got that
basketball hoop over your garage and
your back porch has that great wind
chime and plus there's that beautiful
field yeah but to be fair her basketball
hoop and wind chime aren't as impressive
as your satanic powers to levitate solid
mats and create life from nothingness
McDonald land is still sound like a bit
cooler there Ronald who's gonna make the
decorations for your dad's birthday
party who's gonna be the snowflake in
the school play who's gonna feed mr.
goldfish oh okay yeah it all seems sweet
and cute until you realized this was a
stranger danger commercial come on give
me the first person to think that about
Ronald McDonald I mean look at him in
this commercial
but I think he's missing
[Music]
rym yeah if a strange man dressed like a
clown lures you with magic tricks and oh
I don't know offers you McDonald's to go
with him
chances are you should probably run for
home or that's not like puts it yeah get
out of it just look at the way Ronald
stares at her in this scene if someone
went up to your kid and smiled like this
I pull her the fuck away from him
oh well as much as I make fun of them I
still love both these commercials around
Christmastime McDonald's wishes you a
holiday season with the people who make
you smile
brought to you by a company set to
sabotage your arteries for the rest of
your life by Lindsay so you think
celebrity endorsements are bad now take
a look at what they did to the Caped
Crusader when Batman Returns came out
that's right is he gonna stop rioters or
capturing the culprit responsible for
this crime fuck no he's gonna get him
some diet coke Tyco tiger coke
I need my Tiger car
don't the attractor get out of the way I
mean my bet free alternative to
high-fructose deliciousness
don't you think you're taking this a
little too fuck you mr. malvit hairstyie
car
after all there's just one what we
discover it was Catwoman who was the
culprit all along boy slow leak for her
isn't it I mean was this really her
grand plan shut down the city so she
could tease Batman's bizarre low-calorie
soda fetish
no offense Selina but you can do better
that's the last reason anybody drinks it
the first reason is well now honestly
because Batman Shrek says he loves it so
much he would literally let the city die
just to get the last one that's probably
the best endorsement you could give a
product so if I guess it works another
classic collection of commercials we
can't forget along with that wonderful
jingle that we can't forget their trauma
commercials at all but is it me or does
this sound like the national anthem for
adults who never really did grow up you
know those man children and women
children who never want to do anything
with their lives except play with their
toys I'm telling you it's all because of
this jingle don't believe me the sequel
commercial that came out years later
proves it they're in the exact same
location
my toes are asking for so much yes
you're really fast really it's like no
time has passed they never let their
parents place this is their life
it's the biggest toy store in fact the
more I think about it they're probably
there even to this day Reggie go away
mom
Reggie Winnie I gotta get a job I told
you mom I'm a Toys R Us kid you keep
saying that you couldn't possibly
understand mom I've never gotta have any
grandchildren they just complicate the
plan mom the toys-r-us plan I'm going to
watch old old movies of you and see
where I went wrong Toys R Us cake mom
Toys R Us kid the only other problem I
ever had with these commercials is that
half the toys were never at Toys R Us
you ever noticed that I don't know if it
was a copyright thing or what but half
of these products they were advertising
we're never at the store like imagine
you were a ninja turtle not like I was
look at these fucking things holy shit
I want the life-size dancing ninja
turtles please don't have it ok I'll
take that gigantic teddy bear that he's
bouncing around on well how about that
game where you bombed the battleship
there has to be a game where you can
bomb a battleship this place is an
insult to Joffrey the giraffe great
honey I gotta get a job
sure could be marshmallow back believe
it or not there was actually a period of
time when Count Chocula was a
live-action character and would you like
to see what he looks like
if you how is that it's like a silly
putty combo of the Nesquik rabbit and
fat weird al' yankovic and okay that
chin seriously needs to be censored
I swear I'm looking at Forest Whitaker's
testicles right now and that should not
be under the mouth of an a cereal mascot
something not yet babe I don't even know
what the commercials about it's a
monster that wakes up but when he's fed
Count Chocula he turns back into a kid
okay I can't take your eyes off that
image of Robin Williams face coming out
of a Muppets but if you just yeah turn
away turn it away burn it with acid
Center spice a chocolate monster give no
time what a monstrous illegal part of a
complete breakfast Count Chocula can
satisfy the chocolate monster in you you
stay the fuck away from my chocolate
monster you know you're doing a great
job
oh yeah I don't know how many people
remember this one but for a while
everybody was quoting it it starts off
with a woman working at her job when her
boss obviously starts hitting on her but
you're not using all your assets with a
body like that you can go to places
sexual harassment makes you feel like
less of a person
as a stop sexual harassment booklet at
your public library be a little more
sexy talking about your job
no we're talking about sexual harassment
here and I don't have to take it boom my
early nineties perm just schooled your
ass I don't know what it is there's just
something about how direct she is and
how almost robotic she says it no we're
talking about sexual harassment here
don't poke the boy thing is sometimes I
wonder if this would still work if the
roles were reversed like it feels the
woman hitting on the man my guess at
almost you would be no for one kind of
obviously this happens more to women
that does to men but to men just aren't
smart enough to recognize when they're
being hit on we're kind of dumb that way
if a woman is not interested that's the
one we go for buff a woman is interested
we're blindly naive to it for some
reason if a female boss is hitting on a
male worker he's not gonna catch on to
it anytime soon
except for you you come here yes my lady
it's not a long day hasn't it oh we Oh
henchman number five yes my lady
and you do anything for me what have you
yes my lady
unless someone half your age we're to
kill you in which case I would swear and
allegiance to our blindly okay what do
you say I ride your broomstick for a
while
what do you mean fill my pointy hat
don't follow my totally lost
Jesus wipe it spell it out for you I
want to have sex with you Oh still don't
get it I don't have any other words to
say not one part of that sentence could
be interpreted any other way oh I think
I see what you're saying
good you want me and henchwoman number
12 to hook up
well don't worry my lady I'm still
working on it
hello henchwoman number 12 still not
into you creep she's so into me huh
forget it you're fired
I'm gonna go hit on a flying monkey I
need a better union enjoyably awkward
and quotable as hell we're just talking
about a damn funny commercial here no
we're talking about sexual harassment
here and I don't have to take sexual
harassment by a lady
and it violates the law hey remember
kicks the only cereal commercial that
pretty much listed every single reason
why not to buy it there's no candy stuff
no sugar sprinkles no preservatives no
color
it doesn't how many can your chocolate
in it honestly it's just rabbit
droppings that they painted yellow but
the box is pretty actually they went so
far out of their way to prove how little
is in it that there's actually a
commercial that says there's no flavor
in it listen no car okay Liz yeah that
might be taking the wrong wait guys
especially when you're advertising how
phenomenally boring your product is
little candies bag the funny thing is
that kicks is the only cereal that
tastes different literally with every
single bite you take it's like it gets
worse and worse with every single nip
I'm not even joking you can do a diagram
on the natural progression of what every
bite does to your taste buds the first
bite demonstrates a tasty enjoyable
experience that seems rather satisfying
notice how the smile has deteriorated by
50% on the second bite signifying less
enjoyment out of the experience the
third by clearly shows the mistake one
feels having placed this product in
their mouth surely part of the Box must
have worked its way onto the spoon
clearly they've made a cereal out of
packing peanuts this mistake will not be
made again now kids can get a classic
little golden book free from cakes with
one proof of purchase plus shipping okay
did anyone ever actually send in the
proof of purchase I mean did that ever
happen in the history of mankind
I don't know cereals don't do this but
when they were too cheap to put the toy
in the box they had you pay for a stamp
an envelope as well as shipping and
handling and have the toy delivered to
you a few days later do kids really have
the attention span for that now kids can
get a free dr. Seuss classic to read
with two proofs of purchase plus
shipping but to be fair those books
probably would taste better than the
actual cereal yes contested mother
approve uh yeah let's say it like it is
people kicks kids tolerated mother has
coupons hey kids
there's another turtle rific edition of
now we're talking Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles this is just a straightforward
and promoting the first VHS that ever
came out of the series heroes in a
half-shell there's not a time to talk
about except for one little portion that
might throw you off a bit the video that
reveals the incredible true story
wait a minute well with that the video
that reveals the incredible true story
the incredible true story mmm I'm not a
scientist or anything but I'm just gonna
take a wild guess that the insane
Adventures of four anthropomorphic
life-forms living in the sewer escape
board eating pizza and fighting the
ninja army led by Uncle Phil probably
probably takes place
in the world of fiction it's just so
strange because there's no other way you
can interpret it it's not like he meant
it to be taken this way or part of some
misunderstanding no they straight-up say
it's a true story the video that reveals
the incredible true story what the hell
are we supposed to do with that except
drop a conclusion that fhe are fucking
liars the video that reveals the
incredible true story
that's right they're real if you don't
see him in front of you right now which
probably because you haven't bought
enough of our products would we lie what
I like too is that the announcer clearly
has no problem straight up lying to kids
about it but he almost stumbles when he
has to read what they're actually called
it's Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
as if halfway through he just realized
how stupid this sounded but tried to
keep going anyway teenage mutant whoa
you guys smoking Ninja Turtles still fun
ad just don't have that they GE testify
in court anytime soon now this next
one's a classic for Teresa
oh I see you're a man who likes no I'd
say yeah well what do you say we find
your creamy Center what do you mean do
some old punching the phone that's
something rise up DeLillo's what's wrong
with you I want weird wobbly which
sticks oh I know what you say
you want me and the actress from Game of
Thrones on the plays they'll buy no
bragging chick to hook up well don't
worry I got her on speed dial
hey it's you know she totally wants me
what am I missing here you stole will
you piss off I'm trying to review some
commercials commercials yeah with this
one
[Music]
and this is what happens when a man and
a woman love each other very very much
they will get porno sites together
you're fired I don't even know you
speaking of where babies come from we
got possibly one of the most brutally
honest baby doll commercials ever
they're called but take care of me twins
even the title sounds a little angry
doesn't it like a bitter nickname or
something
this commercial seems determined to show
every stressful terrible part about
raising a child this is my day again not
the happiest words to shout during a
baby commercial but this was like the
most passive-aggressive ad I've ever
seen like saying oh yeah you want a baby
you want a fucking baby to kiss your
social life goodbye because this is your
day this is your entire goddamn day it's
just drooling sneezing feeding changing
running around very much just look at
the smile she gives that's the smile of
I'm about to kill these little bastards
if someone doesn't take him away from me
take care
[Music]
and oh boy what a rushed happy ending
huh hell hell hell hell hell but it's
really goodbye here betweens make four
baby sounds I don't think I've ever seen
a toy that advertised more why not to
buy it
but hey if tearing out your hair to
raise a not human being is your idea of
fun then ah yet another series of
classics the set up is that we see what
happens to a scrawny looking kid if they
keep growing up while drinking their
milk
what girl's gonna go for me with a body
like this hang in there tom I'm you two
years from now cuz you're drinking milk
and working out NewsView Big Brother I'm
drinking milk and in the next few years
it's gonna give me a lot of what I need
for strong bones beautiful skin and a
healthy body
looking closer at these people realized
how phenomenally shallow they are I mean
all of them are totally based on looks
alone in fact one of them even flat-out
says it but I'll bet you're hoping for a
hunk and what all my work is done will
you love me just for my body I can't
live with that
milk it does a body good milk because
personality should come never as long as
they show looks are everything I guess
milk is the ultimate ace in the hole my
body the only difference between me and
the guys is distress hey you can see we
turned out just fine
who is that
every geyser yeah he beats me with a
shovel but you could skate on those ABS
if you're still the same little creep in
a big body
I won't even acknowledge you my brother
the truth is if we really could go into
the future based on what these selfish
little douchebags are like they probably
wouldn't like what they see you may
think I'm a shrimp now big brother but I
drink eat milk which means like our long
hair beautiful skin and become totally
self-absorbed meaning I won't need to
think for myself and instead marry a
wealthy millionaire who only wants me
for my body and they don't feel the same
thing is inside that only the miracle of
cocaine can cure but that's not enough
but then we'll discover rehab and
realize it was all word of God's plan
with my only friend the glass of milk
that started it all milk what the fuck
hey this is my spot maybe I'm reading
too deep into it or maybe they should
emphasize the importance of brain power
as well as body power milk it does a
body good oh good a commercial from
Canada our friendly neighbors from the
north they're always so kind and
everything they do oh look a baby shower
for an expectant mother oh you got the
little girl there and everything oh my
god this is gonna be adorable
that it's a rape whistle what the fuck
can a doubt I mean talk about an
uncomfortable blow to your nads is this
how you do all your serious commercials
start off with something innocent and
light-hearted and then smash it down
into cruel cruel reality I mean it's
like starting off an ad like this you
know the Hardys work doesn't call for
water out of the cooler what do you got
there
I got me a nice bottle of mountain water
cool refreshing big on taste but also
big on satisfaction what do you got
there
I got pancreatic cancer
sheesh I mean this can't be good for
tourism who the hell would want to go to
Canada after learning that statistic do
they have that on the entry sign to the
place
welcome to Canada one in two girls will
be physically or sexually abused
that's pretty awkward I mean how do you
think the expecting mother feels that
it's a rape whistle well grandma just
ruined the baby shower I'm gonna go hit
the vodka
no wait can't drink that's right that's
right again great timing grandma I know
you mean well guys but Jesus it's a rape
whistle everyone rise for the greatest
commercial ever
I know it's current but trust me when I
say it is destined to become a nostalgic
commercial classic it starts off with a
guy just going into a Denny's to get
some pancakes
what follows is a moment of pure and
absolute beauty red white and blue
pancakes huh they taste like
America
[Music]
yes yes they do not extrange old man
Denny's red white and blue pancakes
taste like America my god everything
this country stands for all the
bloodshed all the cries of freedom for
all the wars all the battles all the
patriotic treasures of the world oh we
found here in this pub brilliant piece
of brilliant miss you know some people
say they see America and the Lincoln
Memorial fuck them
some say they see it in the Constitution
of the United States but then to some
say they see it in our purple mountains
Majesty in the glimmering eye of the
honest worker or in Our Stars when they
see that our flag is still there pussy
panties he's at the red white and blue
pancakes from Denny's I mean just look
at this man when he walks in he is lost
and unsure of himself he is afraid to
venture where he has never ventured
before these pancakes
these simple red white and blue pancakes
but where were they lead him but what
will this mean for his future but then
you can see the old man thinking
thinking long and hard about it do I
tell him
do I let him in on the secret of this
nation's greatest landmark yes he is
ready
America
[Applause]
merica and you can see on that young
man's face that he has found salvation
so he once was lost but now has found
Dennis red white and blue pancakes
tell me Oh kind wise sir what other
words of wisdom you have to say about
this great nation of ours America yes
yes good good but what specifically
about America makes it so special
America oh yes yes it goes without
saying but could you possibly go into
more detail America how many fingers am
i holding up
America what color is my hat America you
can't see anything else can you America
and this young man and I have clearly
been reading too deeply into your
uncontrollable mental illness America
well I still stand by this is the
greatest commercial of all time why okay
very calm and cool kid top that
America
okay well thanks for watching my
commercial special everybody I hope you
enjoyed it and hey whatever it did
happen to that horny Wicked Witch it's
hot in here
and I like you very much
lover boy oh I mean the candles the
music the sexy dress what's going on
here don't you like me I'm your girl are
you doing this for
I want you what do you mean I want your
body don't boy I want to have sex with
you totally lost listen here you Bassam
and it was a picture of a spoon on his
wall for some reason I want your
now I guess
[Music]
it's a sexual-harassment and I don't
need to take it what does happened
[Music]
[Applause]
you
felt good feel like I have a reviewed
anything that's talent you for a while
could see there's a are nostalgic things
I can review no my son
there is still one movie left for you to
review before you return to your
nostalgic roots what do you want Joe Joe
do not know this Joe I am your father
Joey knock it off Joe my father wouldn't
have Hedgehog hair like yours far I shut
it off shut it off but seriously there
still is one recent film you have to
answer for Oh what come on I've reviewed
enough recent stuff I'll I'll get back
to my nostalgic roots there's a certain
summer blockbuster I know that you
didn't care for and I'm here to make you
answer for it even if I have to make
sure you review it properly all the way
through well what film is that
really you don't know of course I know
it's just that it's pretty obvious we're
talking about man of speed no sure we're
talking about man esteemeth just want to
build it up for dramatic tension oh well
great now how are we gonna leave on a
cliffhanger I'm pregnant
America